You are listening to radiolab radio from W.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. E. R.
Okay. From the top. You Ready? Yup. Hello. How are you doing?
We're going to start things off today with this lady, Zelda. Gamson.
Come to our little spot. It's beautiful.
She's 80 years old and these days Zelda lives a quiet life by the sea on
Martha's vineyard. Did you have some coffee? She visits with their grandkids,
does some gardening.
We have a bird feeder and it is the bird show of the world.
The life for Zelda wasn't always so calm back in the 60s when our story begins,
she was a very different kind of lady. She even went by a different nickname,
just z. Okay.
I was a smoker 30 years.
I started when I went to college in 1954 first it was just a cigarette here or
there,
letting the bad girl out a bit and then I got hooked really and I couldn't stop.
Went to graduate school, smoked, got my dissertation, smoked,
got my degrees, smoked in somewhere in the fog. She meets. Hi,
my friend Mary. Also a smoker.
Loves smoking made me feel very elegant.
We were very good friends.
We were part in the early sixties of the congress on racial equality together.
They'd organize protests, we would demonstrate,
and the two of them would even go undercover to fight housing discrimination and
the backdrop to all of this social change. Smoke. Yeah. You got it.
I mean, a houses were filled with these ashtray.
How much were you smoking at that point? Probably smoked a packet of day.
I was aware, smoker than Mary and I was sometimes up to two packs a day. Wow.
You know, I had kids, I was pregnant. Um, [inaudible] while you're pregnant.
Guy Did. Wow. Yeah. I feel so guilty about that.
So at a certain point, Zelda and Mary decide they want to stop. Yeah. No.
Mary who had never been as badly addicted to Zelda. It wasn't easy.
It was agonizing, but eventually she's able to do it. Zelda now,
I thought sometimes that I could stop and so I would over and over,
she throw out her cigarettes. Okay. Done. But then,
then I'd be around somebody with cigarettes. Oh yeah.
Any reason that you'd give yourself cancer? My kids, the smell,
the fact that I could die. You'd always lost out to the urge.
And I'd always start smoking again.
And this is how it would go. Resolve failure,
resolve failure. Okay.
So this is not the most unusual situation in the world.
But the question you want to ask right now is like, how do you get out of this?
You want to do something? They happily, but then another part of you says, no,
I don't want to that. So if you against you, what do you do?
I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
and today we the little deal that you make when you are stuck with yourself.
Okay? So before talking with Zelda,
just so happened that I went with Adam Davidson,
one of the planet money guys to visit this fellow Nobel prize winning economist
named Thomas Shelling me.
You're the fifth who's written a whole lot about the seemingly simple idea of
commitment, arranging it so that you can't compromise.
I'll give you an example. Here's the one from ancient Greece, Xenophon,
the Greek who was being pursued by a huge army of Persians had to make a stand
on a hillside, and one of his generals said,
I don't think this is a good location to make our stand.
There's a cliff behind this. There's no way we can retreat if we need to.
And Xenophon told his general exactly. Welcome the cliff. In fact,
he said, here's what we're going to do.
We're going to march our armies that their backs are directly to the cliff.
That way the Persians will know that we can never retreat.
We're bound to fight to the death. You're really binding yourself.
You're not binding the other side. Yeah.
It's attempting to influence somebody else's choice by restricting your own
choice. But then we asked them,
what if your adversary isn't on the outside like the Persians,
but rather it was you. How do you do with Xenophon? Did to yourself?
Yeah, I, uh, I began smoking when I was 17 years old.
I did quit several times,
but I always say
I back. Ooh.
But he did tell. He did give us some suggestions. [inaudible] one in particular.
There was so awesome to use your favorite words.
So diabolical. Yeah.
That we just didn't think anyone would ever do it. Oh,
that is until we met Zelda. Yeah.
Fast forward a few decades,
1984 Marion Zelda now live in different parts of the country.
I happened to be going to a conference in Vermont and Mary picked me up at the
airport, right. And I was smoking when she picked me up,
which was curious because nobody smokes anymore. She said,
why Celta are you still smoking? And Zelda said, yeah,
and don't tell me to stop. I was very belligerent.
Yes. So I went to the conference and smoked.
And were they guilty cigarettes? No, they were delicious.
But what Mary said was starting to worm its way into her brain.
Are you still smoking? Still Smoking, still smoking stores.
And when she dropped me off at the airport, I said, okay, Mary,
as if she had been putting pressure on me, which she wasn't at all.
If I ever smoke again,
I'm going to get $5,000 to the Ku Klux Klan.
What did she say? $5,000 to the Klu Klux Klan, correct?
[inaudible]
this was shelling suggestion. It couldn't work,
but he didn't think anyone would ever do it.
$5,000 to the Ku Klux Klan. It just came out of my math.
You know how horrible they are, right? Sure. So heinous. But
her and Mary made a deal. A pact. If sell the smoked,
she'd have to tell Mary to send the KKK her money,
take it out of my savings or something. And you were really serious.
You were going to do this. Yeah,
but I have to say after I made this pledge to marry under my breath,
I said, but I can't be responsible if she smokes again.
What if she smokes again? If she smokes again?
Who's the she in that sentence? Me You.
What does that mean? Well, that means that a part of me,
the part of me that was smoking and that might pick up smoking again was an
alien part. You're saying you were two people at that moment? Yeah.
And she z didn't really want to stop smoking.
She she, yeah.
After the pact, Zelda says that often when she would fall asleep,
I would dream of myself smoking and she'd wake up in a terrible sweat reach for
her cigarettes. But every time she says this other thought,
we just rush into her mind. The KKK robes burning crosses,
lynchings. Oh Gosh. She'd throw the cigarettes down. I could.
The idea of them having her money,
I can't even imagine it.
[inaudible]
sounds like you really backed yourself up against the cliff. I did.
Zelda had found a thought that was hotter than the years
and she didn't smoke again. Never again. No. That was it.
Cold Turkey.
[inaudible]
look at this.
There's a picture of me on a cruise that bill and I took your sheet. Yes,
it's a profile picture of the cigarette.
I look gorgeous there. That's best picture ever taken of me.
[inaudible]
now, if we are many people on the inside,
and we've talked about this on the show before,
how like our brain is literally divided into these camps that sometimes wrestle,
right? Fight. Well, the problem,
I think the problem is quoting to Thomas shelling is that these cells never
exist simultaneously. We're never at the table together.
The one who's in charge never confronts the other.
I guess that makes it hard to compromise.
Well though, you know, there is another way to think about the problem.
Things that are offered right now have so much more power than things that are
offered in the future. Oh, this is David Eagleman.
He's a neuroscientist and he says, you know, really,
you could think about this whole thing as a battle about time.
We'll make all sorts of very poor economic decisions now versus later. We,
if something is offered right now versus later,
and when you look at the neuroimaging,
it becomes clear that there are different parts of the brain that are,
that are battling this out in the now. Parts are way stronger. Yes.
Here's the key. What she's doing in the case of the cigarettes is she's saying,
I know that I want to win this longterm battle,
but I'm having a heck of a time doing it.
But if I can make the longterm plan tied into a different immediate feeling of
disgust, then all I have to do is have the disgust battle. The the desire.
I see. So she's,
what she's done is she's turned this battle into a present tense battle on both
sides. I want a cigarette now versus I hate the KKK now.
Precisely.
So it's a now versus now thing and I think that's the only way we ever win these
longterm battles is to give them some sort of emotional salience.
Some reason why they matter to us right now. Otherwise it will never work.
And there are any number of ways of doing this. Here
is how Thomas shelling did it,
1980 gather my children together and I said I quit and that they should never
have respect for their father again if I
returned to smoking and he never, he never did. And that was it for him.
Huh?
The thing I like about about those two stories is that like there's a case where
like, okay, say you've got these cells battling in your head,
I've got the now part in the later part and the later parts week. Yeah.
In this case, the later part found a way to trick the now parts,
and this has a name, this kind of approach.
It's called a Ulysses contract in the Iliad.
This is a moment where you list these in as men have to sail past the island of
the sirens and you list these nos. If they hear the siren song, they're dead.
Sailors were so attracted to these melodies that they would steer towards them
and crash their ships into the rocks and die. So on his way there,
before the music started, he came up with a plan.
He had his men lash him to the mast with ropes so that he couldn't move and he
had them fill their own ears with bees wax. And he said,
no matter what I do, no matter how,
I'm just sticky waiting or shouting or acting like a crazy man,
just keep rowing. Just keep going. And so when they got to the sirens
[inaudible]
Ulysses,
he goes nuts and he's screaming and yelling and telling the men go towards the
women. We don't want to pass this up.
And of course the men have bees wax in their ears.
They're not swayed by the siren song because he had planned for this,
the present tense Ulysses,
by using his men and the rope had literally bound the future Ulysses to the mast
because he knew that guy would be weak.
[inaudible]
we can just move off the ocean for just a moment. Gun. Get out of your ocean
radio. What a weird medium. Anyway,
what is the bargain that you strike isn't just about something, you know, very,
very small. And now like this puff of smoke,
what if it's a deal that you have to do that we'll decide what you're going to
do for every day of the next 40 years. Yeah. What that,
well, this brings us to a story from our producer pap. Walter's ready. Okay.
Set it up. Okay. Uh, okay.
I'm in Chinatown about a year ago corner of Hell. And, uh,
my friend Jenny posted something on Twitter. It said, overheard.
I flipped the coin and I lost my life.
Yeah.
I flipped a coin and lost my life. Yes. And what's Twitter? Yeah.
I mean she, she actually heard someone say this. Yeah. She was just like,
she's a reporter. She was just chatting with the guy and he's,
and he said he said that to her. I flipped a coin and I lost my life. Wow.
What was the context I, while she was getting a massage in Chinatown.
And how would that phrase come up in the middle of a massage? I don't,
I honestly don't know. But she's a reporter. Did she, did she ask? I say,
get your hands off me man, and tell me the story.
I don't know exactly what went down, but I asked her what the situation was.
She said that she basically didn't know anything,
but she just heard that she heard it and she told me that it was at this place
that was like either at one of seven different addresses that she gave me.
So I just wondered around,
do you know of some place around here called health trail massage place has no
idea. No.
Wandered around to several different addresses and eventually I found this tiny
little storefront. There's a little sign,
the fee kind of hidden.
Oh, you want to see my,
my son and I found the guy who said the thing. Hi. Hi. How are you?
I'm okay. His name is Dennis Dennis.
And you just asked him how you tell me about this coin flip. Can you tell me,
can you, so when did this happen? How about four years ago?
A was 26 and my brother was uh, 21.
Both of them had gone to college, dentist for photography, his brother for art,
joy, and they'd come out of school with these big dreams in new places,
meeting New People, making a live and making money.
But that hadn't really worked out. Yeah, no, Jeff for me,
you're having a hard time finding jobs and they ended up living at home with
their dad. Yeah, with my dad.
So basically I had to stay in home two picture and my brother,
he's just working at a restaurant. No life either.
So this is basically post college flail. Yeah. Like they're stuck.
Stuck in the middle of the road. That's what happened to us.
One day their dad comes up to them and says, look guys,
one of you guys gotta follow. I need one of you.
I don't care which one of you,
but I need one of you to take over the family business.
My father's getting all just designed.
I eat above you come out or one of your [inaudible] so one of them now has to
carry on his, his thing. Yeah. What is it they do here?
Into this massage parlor? Yeah. Since we're not interested. Yeah. Nieto.
There's what really want to do it. That's Chi Chi.
Will Dennis's little brother cause touching people food.
It's some kind of disgusting. Right. You know,
there's always a hairy guy or like some girls like busted toes.
Disgusting and annoying. Facing your father for 24 hours. Seven days a week.
Yeah. A little more than I can take. Like, I love my dad,
but you just don't want to follow your dad with footstep. But the dad says,
get over it. It's about family, keeping the business alive,
keeping the technique he has alive in the whole channel town.
Don't take any massage place or any therapy place.
We'll have my father tell me it's a special kind of thing. Yeah,
it's this like deep tissue acupressure, painful type massage. I don't know.
Have Jenny told you? That is really, really painful. Anyhow,
they're sitting at home and this question is kind of like silently hanging over
them for days and weeks till one day at a friend's place, having some tea,
talking about their dad and Dennis looks up at his brother and says as make a
bet. Let's do the tease thing. The one,
let's see what the, what does TD saying? Well,
Dennis says when you're drinking loose tea, the Chinese, right?
You put the leaves right in the bottom of your cup and you pour the water over
them and usually the leaves float up to the top flat on the surface of the tea.
But every now and that every tank cuff you might see the tips is floating and
the rest of the body is inside a water. So like the stem sort of yeah.
And then the leaf is hanging down. Yeah.
Do you mean like every so often instead of the whole leaf being on the top of
the water, the leafy park just falls to the bottom and yeah,
and just the tip of the stem is touching the surface of the water.
Almost like it's hanging down from the surface of the water. And this is rare.
Yeah. So when you get that estimate, it's good luck.
And is that like a traditional, this one out over people and it was doing that.
That's how we understand that. And we was kid, so we just decide, okay,
well we get that whoever gets the most lucky tea leaves,
well we'll win you out. You don't need to worry. My Dad,
whoever lost from a font of footstep, they trusted their whole future to this.
Yeah. It was like a spur of the moment thing. They were, didn't we? Yeah.
We didn't really plan anything.
Some pipe people just flip a coin and they can't figure out which way should
they go. So this is flip a coin.
When you pull all the hot water in,
they will like rolling out loud like a small tomato inside they are spinning
and then once it's done,
each cup has a layer of tea leaves on the surface and Dennis notices. So whoa,
look at it that he'd gotten one, one piece that was a wow. As an incredible.
Then you looked over to his brother's cup.
Oh my God.
Way More of these lucky leaves. It was pretty obvious. You know,
he lost and there wasn't even close. No.
Do you remember if he was like angry or looks like he was deepen thought.
I don't thing like damn, this is like as the west thing in my life.
Um,
and it basically was because now he was bound by these tea leaves to go and work
for his dad. Oh, what happened
Ben? Did you first come here to work? I don't feel like touching anybody foot.
So he forced me to touch me for did he have to like grab your hands and sit
down, take off his shoes? What are washing his feet. Okay.
That's kind of disgusting. So is this telling me to try to work on it?
His Dad eventually said practice on your friends. Oh, is that Oh god, no,
they still hate me right now for giving them all the pain. When that was gone,
do you remember like what was going through your head? Were you like,
what am I doing? Like did you feel like you're on the wrong track? Well,
um, I don't know how to explain. Here's the funny thing.
Then it says that there came a point after a month,
look at all my father fear that of the disgusting anymore.
I feel kind of like it. He likes it. I don't know why. It's just like making me,
ah, they seem nice to work on people. Um,
I don't know how to explain. I just stopped fall in love with this job.
Yeah. I don't know. How's it happen? I just, I,
I working here seven days a week, so become part of my life.
Wake up in the morning, come here, work, go home, sleep,
come and work. So as those become part of my five year, when I got a day off,
I don't know what to do, where to go and just staying at home,
let me come back out here and work as what happened.
It's just that I think that's how I fall foreign love is,
you don't know how to happen when it's happened. It just happened.
It was a good lows. I was thinking, I left this job.
So it sounds like you made this deal with fate and he just got lucky.
No. Now Kai has a slightly different read on the whole thing. So if he had one,
would you have had to do it? No, no, no, no, no.
Kai says the whole Tealeaf deal. It was really just about Dennis.
I think at that point in the back of his head, he wanted to do it.
Just an excuse. I think he was just looking for a sign. I'd have to ask him,
I guess. And when I did ask Dennis, he didn't really agree with this brother.
It's just a how you say sorry. But he didn't entirely disagree either.
Not that because I wanted to do it just like it's kind of,
I'm using my brother to push me to work. My Dad. That's what he,
what do you mean by that? I don't think he wanted to make his own decision.
It might be better. I just worked for my dad, but I don't want him to face him.
So if my brother just pushed me, okay, I'll be facing him. Ah,
that could be what happened.
So we just needed a push.
Would you be thing to do?
No. You know, when you think about it, why is that wimpy? Well, I mean, he did.
He wanted to be a Massoud, you know, and he didn't know what he wanted. Yo,
he knew and he set up his brother to make him do it. So it's very know,
if you call it wimpy, call it wimpy.
I call it a powerfully wimpy, muscularly wimpy.
Meaning what? What does that mean? Meaning that, oh, I got one for you.
I'm going to lay this. You ready for this?
Maybe the new strength is understanding your own wind penis.
What do you think about that? Ooh, I just tie.
Just tied you into a philosophical, not right there, buddy.
You're going to be thinking about that one for years. I'm thinking about it.
I'm over thinking about it. Then take it into the complexity.
Can I speak now? Yeah. David's going to say something. This is who we are.
I mean, that's the reality on the ground. We're just weak. We need help,
and I actually think this gives,
this gives us a new way to think about and understand virtue.
I think it gives us a much richer view of human nature.
It's the Pat Walters, our Chinatown correspondent, and two Thomas Shelling,
who's written many, many books,
including the strategy of conflict and to Adam Davidson from the amazing planet
money team and to David Eagleman whose latest book is incognito.